if you or someone you know has high
blood pressure this video will help you
understand what it is and why it's
important to keep it under control
over time high blood pressure will
damage the walls of your arteries this
damage can lead to life-threatening
conditions
for example an artery wall may become
weak and form an enlarged area called an
aneurysm the wall may burst
and bleed into the tissue around it
in another example damage to an artery
wall may attract certain substances in
your blood such as cholesterol fat and
calcium they may form a buildup called a
plaque
as the plaque gets bigger blood flow in
the artery is reduced
can stick to the plaque and form solid
clumps called clots blood clots further
reduce or completely block your blood
flow
if this happens in your brain it can
lead to a stroke
in your heart it can lead to a heart
attack in another example damage to the
arteries in your kidneys may reduce
their ability to work properly this can
lead to kidney disease
in a final example damage to your
arteries makes your heart beat even
harder which raises your blood pressure
even more and can lead to heart failure
if you have questions about high blood
pressure or any medications you have
been prescribed for it speak with your
doctor it is important to take your
medications as directed and report any
side effects you have